the justice department is making a
surprise return to the sex abuse
investigation of a former usa gymnastics
doctor that's larry nassar deputy
attorney general lisa monaco says the
doj has new information and will review
a decision not to prosecute two former
fbi agents accused of ignoring
complaints against nassar jeff pigues is
at the justice department with more on
the story jeff this is certainly an
interesting turn and i would think many
of the victims will welcome this news
yeah indeed and gail that was the
bombshell that came out of this senate
judiciary committee hearing yesterday
and as you noted a lot of people caught
by surprise even some of the reporters
covering the event but what the deputy
attorney general did not reveal is what
that new information is
the victims did not receive
the response
or the protection
that they deserved in a senate hearing
tuesday deputy attorney general lisa
monaco told lawmakers the department of
justice was revisiting its decision
not to criminally charge two former
agents involved in the larry nassar
sexual abuse investigation but i do want
the committee and frankly i want the
survivors to understand how
exceptionally seriously we take this
issue they had legal legitimate evidence
of child abuse and did nothing the
announcement came just three weeks after
an emotional senate hearing
in which former usa gymnast responded to
a report released by the doj's office of
the inspector general
that report concluded that fbi agents at
the indianapolis field office repeatedly
failed to properly handle key components
of the nassar investigation in 2015
including failure to notify local and
state officials about the allegations
and giving incomplete and inaccurate
information about their handling of the
case to internal fbi investigators we
suffered and continued to suffer because
no one at fbi usag or the usopc did what
was necessary to protect us but monaco's
testimony has given former u.s olympic
gymnast and nasa abuse victim jessica
howard hope for real justice i truly was
in shock it's one of the first times
that somebody
from the government at that level has
taken responsibility there might
actually be consequences and that in and
of itself gave me an inner security that
i have not had
this entire time these institutions need
to learn that no one is above the law
in a statement the attorney who is
representing several nassar victims john
manley called that announcement
yesterday long overdue we did reach out
to the two agents involved in the
original investigation but we have yet
to hear back gail
all right jeff thanks